>> Deep learning with neural networks has
opened up a whole new world of possibilities for
building AI solutions including huge advances in computer vision.
Now of course you know that an image is just an array of
numbers representing pixel intensities.
So in theory, we could just feed
the pixel values into a fully connected neural network,
and get a class prediction.
In practice, we don't actually feed
the image data directly into a fully connected network like this.
Because it would include a whole bunch of pixel values that
don't have anything to do with the class of object in the image.
We need a smart approach that extracts
meaningful features from the image
before trying to predict its class.
What we do is we apply multiple filter kernels,
each initialized with some random weights to the image.
We convolve the filter kernels across
the image so that each one produces a feature map.
Typically, we apply a rectified linear unit or
ReLU activation function to
convert any negative pixel values to zero.
After one or more convolution layers,
we can also apply pooling or down-sampling kernel.
This is passed across the feature maps in
the same way as a convolutional filter kernel.
But this time we simply take the maximum value.
The end result is
a smaller feature map that tends
to emphasize the activated pixels.
So putting it all together,
we start with an image,
and then we use convolutional layers to apply filters.
With pooling layers to down sample
the feature maps generated by the filters.
All of these layers form
the feature extraction portion of our network.
After which, we flattened the feature maps that we've extracted.
Then we feed them into
a fully connected layer to map them to class label probabilities.
The whole thing is called a Convolutional Neural Network,
and it's the basis for
modern deep learning image classification solutions.
We train it using the same train backpropagate
and validate approach,
we use for a fully connected neural network,
adjusting the weights and biases in
the fully connected neurons as well as
the convolutional filter kernals in each epoch.